citizens of the reject Nation we are going to
watch today a very special Last of Us video
called unlocking a surprising genius companion
series part one it's a very very long video this
will be the first video John and I are covering
together uh regarding last of us since uh he has
not played the game he's covering it separately
with Tara Erickson and then I'm covering it with
Andrew Gordon but yeah film wise is a new
channel launched by Philip Molina who you
might know from his work with a new rock stars
but now he's got a new channel going this video
has been hyped for me like non-stop I know that
Philip spent weeks on this video maybe a couple
of months heavy spoilers who's killing it with
his coverage for this series right now actually
said this is the best video he's seen regarding
the Last of Us I've had several people hit me up
saying that maybe we should react to it yeah
I'm here to tell you that we are going to do
that right now you can subscribe to filmwise
link in the description box uh you can check
out the original video I actually don't know
what the angle is on it I'm here to support
and I want to see what's going on and enough
people have asked us to check it out so here
we are to do it before we do that please go
ahead leave a like let's see what's in store
[Music] to make a
case what to do Essence lightsaber first time
Hollywood took a swing it's kind of become
this elusive mystery an unattainable goal since
that Super Mario Brothers movie there have been
countless attempts but all they've done is make
it seem less possible to translate the magic of
a video game narrative to any other screen
even the writer and showrunner of this new
Last of Us show Craig Mason long before taking
on this job agreed that video game adaptations
are historically terrible a lot of these assets I
think ultimately become junk so I like a mountain
of failed adaptations behind them a budget
of over 100 million dollars and an industry
landscape that's about ready to say yeah we only
want sequels and adaptations but let's go ahead
and forget about video games and Source material
because they don't work there is an immense
amount of pressure for HBO to get it right this
time so then why would they give this seemingly
impossible task to the same guy who made these
movies but I can tell when Danger's near I just
he made those movies yeah before Chernobyl Craig
Mason does not have the most like dramatically
Hefty or like widely respectable filmographers
had no idea holy crap I was I was really thrown
for a loop there yeah I think it even worked
as a hangovers or something like that yeah well
that's fascinating to hear I mean I gotta say
so far it's Hardy just the setup for what we're
about to watch and yeah the editing on this is
phenomenal already what the TV documentary here
yeah it really feels that way and I think what
Last of Us is getting right is the fact that
they're focusing on character and emotion first
before focusing on bringing gameplay to life and
I think that's a lot of time where a lot of these
video game adaptations go wrong it's like what do
they enjoy most when they're actually playing
the game but always said if you're gonna adapt
something go for the TV show because it started
working out pretty well for the animated medium
when they're doing that and now live action
they're proving it we're proving it here
welcome to filmwise in this three-part mini-series
we're going to be dismantling the idea of The
Impossible Video Game adaptation and by analyzing
the structure of this story and of the world the
show takes place in we're going to figure out
what's really going on here not just in the
last of us but in this seemingly insane choice to
hand the reins to Craig Mesa a choice he himself
knows is pretty scary they didn't have to draw
so much from my bottomless well of self-loathing
instead I I borrowed from my bottomless well of
fear here's the thing Craig Mason is exactly the
right person to make this adaptation a success
the only wrong move for him and for HBO would be
to not even try and much like the themes of this
story itself when it comes to Joel's Journey the
threat of a global pandemic or protecting the ones
you love the greatest risk is not taking one by
the way if you're wondering where I'm getting
all this from well we're lucky enough to have
the words of Craig Mason himself to help guide
us in analyzing what this story is really about
my name is Craig Mason and this is scriptnotes a
podcast about screenwriting and things that are
interesting to screenwriters on a screenwriting
podcast Craig Mason tells us how he builds here's
how he says we should start but when you think of
the idea the very next question you should ask is
what central dramatic argument would fit really
well with this that's how we made superhero movies
we'll be seeing multiple episodes of the show at a
time but in this video we're going to focus mostly
on the pilot because it not only encompasses all
of act one of the larger story but each scene
within it is setting the groundwork for all of
the Mega themes that will come later for instance
in the show's very first scene it immediately
is planting the seed for these Show's entire
Central dramatic arguments the story not from the
game it's a clip from a 1968 TV talk show where a
scientist predicts how Humanity could fall to a
threat as seemingly benign as a fungus but only
if we ignore the warnings of things like say
global warming what if the world was to get
slightly warmer well now there is reason to evolve
cordyceps aspergillus any one of them could become
capable of borrowing into our brains and taking
control billions of Puppets permanently fixed
on one unifying goal to spread the infection to
every last human alive by any means necessary the
jokes that the host makes indicates how their
world began to responded this morning but of
course that's not just true for their world
there is no pandemic flu in our country at
this time but if we wait for a pandemic to appear
it will be too late to prepare we have to put in
place an infrastructure that allows us to see it
quickly isolate it quickly respond to it quickly
yeah that's something that I think this show in
particular better than the video game does is draw
on real world things that people would say are
political but they're just scientific [__] that
we're dealing with all the time and I think that
this show really knows how to demonstrate that
in a phenomenal way and I haven't seen Chernobyl
of what I imagine about what goes on in Chernobyl
Craig Mason already had a really great knack for
that to implement some of those flourishes over to
here whereas a lot of shows and movies might
get too bogged down with it he knows how to
make it feel more lived in and it was cool is that
Chernobyl is a true story and he's now taking this
into a fictional realm sure kind of extrapolating
off of that because so much of Chernobyl is about
watching the human error and hubris that can lead
yes to a disaster such as this and then here you
multiply it by all these issues that we can't seem
to agree on just in culture and those agreements
could or disagreements could be incredibly costly
as illustrated by what they're putting out here
and it's not overly preachy as of now but it
does seem like they did put a solid effort
into going yeah what can we actually contemplate
with all this cool stuff that we're doing with
infectious and all that stuff what are the dangers
of inaction and we answer it through the stories
of Joel and Ellie the global pandemic around them
and those around us I'm actually not talking about
covet here by the way but more on that later
and it even applies to Craig Mason's own path in
making this show and if at any point you think I'm
reaching when I'm showing the true meaning of the
story has to do with something in our world just
know that's what Mason has told us to look out
for himself everything we wanted to do was to say
to people listen we're showing you extraordinary
circumstances a world that's Fallen apart and
there are monsters and all this stuff is happening
but it is applicable to your life right now here
in the world that isn't falling apart after the
idea of a dramatic argument are introduced Mason
says you have to introduce your protagonist
and their Ordinary World what ordinary emotions
here is that the protagonist's life essentially
exemplifies their ignorance of the theme of
the argument that you want them to believe
eventually in fact they believe the opposite of
that argument soon after we jump forward to 2003
we'll like that protagonist Joel Miller and his
Ordinary World which is a life stuck in time he's
doing that purpose for you he believes the exact
opposite of inaction being dangerous he goes out
of his way to avoid the passage of time because
acknowledging it and taking action is what he
thinks is a true danger he ignores his birthday he
sleeps through his alarm he hates time so much he
even keeps his only wristwatch locked away in a
drawer one change from the game by the way this
is all happening on Joel's 36th birthday how
old are you again 36. but in the video game it
says 32nd ironically that's right around how old
Craig Mason was when his first scary movie came
out and just like these first events in the show
that was also 20 years ago my God this is all a
cathartic release for Craig Mason to get his
frustrations out I'm working on scary movies
I'm gonna draw from my pain of the studio
anxieties that were dealt my way anguish of
paying my dues to the system was franchise sequels
oh that's gnarly I actually never picked up on
that whole idea of Joel kind of resistance Against
Time yeah that is a really really interesting take
subtly done yeah at that time Craig said he'd
actually been hoping to move toward more adult
fair but his boss is at Miramax suddenly dropped
this scary movie thing in his lab and then seven
years went by so just like Joel he finds himself
in an unfulfilling but relatively safe category
stuck doing the same thing again and again but
at least not risking any true loss however the
reality is for both Craig again for Joel that
time keeps ticking anyway and that's embodied
by Joel's daughter Sarah she's the antithesis
to Joel's thesis she wants to celebrate or at
least experience each moment she's growing
she forces Joel to acknowledge his birthday
she constantly asks about what's on the news
she even has a textbook on how to run a school
news program she probably would have been a
reporter sometimes Mason makes Sarah this way
to begin Joel's Evolution using What's called
the hegelian dialectic that's a fancy way to
say that there's a Perpetual tug of war between
any two ideas a thesis and an anti-thesis Hegel
the guy that came up with the dialectic he said
that it's all really just a cycle neither side
really wins so much as they give up on tugging
and land at a newly combined thesis a point we
call synthesis cool that's also a point damn
I love that yeah he ain't done tugging now
it's important to note just because they are
automatically opposed doesn't mean Angel and
his daughter don't have a deep bond without
saying a word about it we can subconsciously
tell that the guitar in the living room the
poster of the Clash and Sarah's room the open
CD cases in Joel's room even the magnet on
the fridge for the Austin City Limits Music
Fest those are symbols of a deep connection they
share dude this editing is phenomenal yeah it's
so engrossing how far are we or seven minutes
this is Beautiful Jesus Christ this is insane
yeah absolutely there's been a lot of those in a
YouTube video it's just kind of editing this this
feels like a TV special so mind-blowing holy crap
top-notch job I can't get over it that's gnarly a
different way they can communicate outside the
limitations of time through their appreciation
for music yeah that's it for those of the last
of a sequel you actually know that Joel was once
an aspiring musician part of Joel and Sarah's
morning routine seems to be enjoying a bit of
music together but we can see the example
of how messages hide in that music as the
song playing here is White Flag by Dido and
afterwards I presume he says I don't already
the lyrics are about someone who knows that the
days left in their relationship are numbered
but I have no plans to move
on or Surrender their love
no detail wasted it's a sweet sentiment but it's
taken to an unhealthy place with the bridge of the
song foreshadowing even 20 years from now Joel's
still gonna pretend he's moved on almost seeming
like he never was a father at all but he's still
secretly hurting just the same yeah we could have
predicted Joel's reaction because as you remember
he fast bodies the thesis that you can stay safe
as long as you freeze time so that's why it's up
to Sarah the antithetical character to remind him
of the truth somehow intuitively she knows their
time left is limited and by fixing Joel's watch
she's forcing him to bring time back into his life
because as she says later you were never gonna do
it for yourself oh no to be clear Joel's refusal
to accept the passage of time doesn't mean he's
without purpose he's actually driven to freeze
time as a sad attempt to be the ultimate protector
even from things like secondhand smoke flip it
out this is likely a philosophy he inherited
as not only is his watch probably a hand-me-down
from either the Vietnam era or World War II but
his Hunter's knife is actually a Vietnam standard
issue Buck 110. whether or not Joel was a soldier
before since that Desert Storm bumper sticker
we see might actually belong to Tommy definitely
it's clear that his family operates under the
belief that protecting others is the ultimate
purpose though through Sarah's fascination with
the engraving of wild horses on that tucked away
knife we can see a symbol of Joel's past and
his Carefree spirit being locked away as well
and for the zombie genre it's actually a
bit unusual to do so much establishing of
a character stuck in stasis rather than just
letting them react to the insane chaos around
them as we'll soon see with the 20-year time
Jump this show actually skips the adjustment
period that entire other stories are set in
that's on purpose I'm not a huge fan of the
zombie genre when the genre creates a situation
in which every decision is a matter of life and
death I get fatigued by it I am fascinated by
people's responses to things it's interesting
watch characters respond in various ways to
A disruption of stasis that can be overcome
speaking of stasis after the movie three
Craig was also trapped in his own frozen
career bubble pumping out the same content over
and over again despite it not being fulfilling I
mean the pressure that we were under from the
weinsteins to make those movies as quickly as
possible was brutal and we couldn't do them as
well as we wanted to do them but that's Craig
just embodying his own form of story structure
your hero can't shake themselves out of stasis
for some reason your video is just making me
wonder what was the scary movie idea that he had
all of these deeper themes of synthesis
and all that what philosophical debate
does this parody movie have
to offer what is the thesis
keeps coming back it's a scary movie three the
easiest way to communicate you know when you're
trying to tell someone about the last of us it's
kind of like a zombie game I don't think I've ever
called it a zombie game it's a survival game but
a lot of people often refer to it as that just
because there's some similar things infection they
behave like rabbit I think having Craig Mason on
board is perfect when that's his thought process
because it allows him to respect the material
without going I want to change the material a lot
of adaptations actually go wrong is when they I
don't really like this I'm going to make it how I
like it he's like the perfect middle ground for it
well and the game is from the outside at least
has always sounded like it's not your average
zombie game it's a really story driven thing and
I feel like that's also to kind of a saving grace
that helps this even further work yeah I don't
know what the best way is to leave something I
wish I did back in the world of The Last of Us
Sarah's teacher underlines this moment of debate
that Heroes arrive to in their stories she asks
the key question in a sentence is where are you
songs in life just like in writing a character
is defined by their choices and their actions
a character who doesn't take action is not only
aimless there aren't even really existing in their
own plot or in their own life Sarah NPC self and
for her father against that ever ticking clock of
Reality by the way if you aren't sold on Sarah's
obsession with time let's just check out where
she goes next what's really interesting about this
moment is what Sarah knows is true but Joel is in
denial and that's that time is universal there's
no hiding from it for everyone everywhere no
matter what choices they make they're all about to
experience the exact same thing in the very same
moments the consequences up next Sarah visits with
her neighbors and it's Mrs Adler who hints at the
path that Joel's gonna have to take people out
there need to get right with Jesus three Nails
Plus One cross equals four given that's not to
say Joel needs to find Jesus apologize I need
to seek salvation or Redemption for his sins of
inaction find the light Craig Mason was feeling
this as well because after years of making those
spoof movies I would argue the spoof is dead you
could tell it didn't feel good to be contributing
those Works to the world if there's one thing that
people who wrote comedy features know it's that
they're out there with their knives and you are
gonna have to face the music sooner or later that
same stress about how little time we all have is
why Sarah lies to Mrs Adler about her father
being home soon you know what my dad's gonna
be back real soon I should go she knows he won't
be home for hours but she also knows how we spend
our time is the only thing about time that we can
actually control this is another lesson that Joel
actually needs to learn which is why it's up to
Sarah to point out that he's failed on his promise
and that he's home late again it's 10. oh no he's
not only running out of time to celebrate his own
birthday he's running out of time to spend with
her literally this ultimate failure in his current
way of thinking is similar to the last spoof movie
that Craig Mason made it's called superhero movie
and it was the first time he not only wrote the
spoof movie but he also took the helm and directed
it too and it was by far his worst perceived
it wasn't just the worst reviewed it actually
earned a hundred million dollars less wow no
I'll tell you the worst situation is when you
have a bad movie that also doesn't make a lot of
money it was for me to work on it and make it and
then also to watch burn this experience was so bad
it took Craig 15 years to Don the director's cap
again and that was actually on this very episode
oh no way dang I missed the episode of the show
he directed you can understand why we're paying so
much extra attention to the choices he made within
it but back to the early 2010s the choices he made
then implied an initial search for salvation by
focusing on slightly higher brow comedy though
only slightly with his work on Hangover 2 and 3
and identity theft these films were certainly more
successful than superhero movie but they still
actually only performed about as well as the scary
movies films did especially critically just like
how Mason could have kept making spoof movies but
his refusal to showed hints of a desire to change
and Elevate Joel also makes new promises he's
gonna bring a cake tomorrow he'll wear the watch
though he actually still jokes about refusing to
accept its time keeping it the thing is we know
these people haven't really changed yet we're just
seeing hints that they could you made Identity
Thief I want to see the credit yeah I was like is
he a writer on it what did he do that a hard time
paying attention after him he's got to be the
writer of it yeah I'm trying to pay attention
to Phillips video right now but I'm really stuck
on the fact that he made one of the movies I I
hate that movie so much most tedious like arduous
movies to sit through yeah game has humor through
the characters and I think he brings that to
life as well I know he's not the only director
only writer on this show he's the showrunner does
an excellent job still bringing those qualities
to life in a very beautiful way and I think this
use of time is is also very neat from a writing
standpoint when I watched the first episode I
thought it was more about the ticking clock of
the impending doom coming around the corner and
I was aware of the whole thing with the watch how
it's going to break and Sarah and all that but I
didn't register whatsoever oh there's actually a
much deeper meaning to this whole the symbolism of
time here of how it reflects upon the characters
internal turmoils and struggles and the arcs are
gonna have to go on throughout the series we know
Joe hasn't really embraced change because he even
hesitates to get his brother out of jail he has to
be guilted into taking action tonight I'm in here
all weekend nope by the way that Tommy doesn't
have the same issue that Joel has he saw someone
in trouble and he immediately jumped into savory
then as another clock points out just how little
time is left in this day moments before midnight
it's possible that Joel's gonna come to regret
this action he's taking he might dig his heels
in even further and think he should have never
stepped away and accepted this pull from outside
his bubble of safety that's because while he
doesn't know it at this time later he's gonna
remember that these are the last moments of the
last full day he could have been with his daughter
whether she knew why or not she was right that
this time would be the end of their relationship
their final moments together their last of us and
the fact that Joel's gonna blame himself for this
that's foreshadowed in one of the slight changes
from the game because yes both stories deal with
infected neighbors but only in the show do we meet
the adlers and just like how Sarah cares for her
father she makes him breakfast she encourages him
to take vitamin C vitamin C there's another child
Mrs Adler who dotes on her parent feeds her gives
her everything she needs but ultimately she's
killed by that parent so since again these are new
characters for the show it's a purpose full choice
to show that ironically when the parent does
finally feed it's on the child that's a distorted
truth about how Joel will come to feel like his
actions cost Sarah her life in some ways at least
to Joel it's like he did feed on her he let her
take a bullet for him up next in Craig maiden's
story structure is the event that finally shakes
the hero out of stasis the inciting incident is
the moment their belief shatters point of the
inciting incident is to specifically disrupt a
character's stasis it destroys it and it forces
a choice on the character that belief-shattering
choice for Joel is made pretty quickly when he's
witnessed enough to know stasis ain't an option he
can't stay home they can't even stay in Austin
now you might think this would force Joel to
accept that trying to keep Time Frozen isn't the
right way to do things but be it subconsciously
or maybe superstitiously you can imagine that
somewhere deep in his psyche he knows the moment
that he let himself wear a working watch he
let time unfreeze and everything fell to [__]
haha I think it would have been great if when
he showed up at the house he's like I'm going
back inside I don't want time to work against
me I'm taking this watch off I'm gonna go down
yeah I'm gonna put that Ninja movie back on
TV I'm staying in the exact order of things
of how I like it to be as I refuse to adjust
to the times right now will not move forward
in inch yeah I would like to see that version of
the show at last one episode yeah it's my birthday
hey if it kills me that's how I write that's
how I would drive my themes home I'm just gonna
completely negate this inciting incident and I am
going to not you I have a static character till I
die ruin all Logic for the whole audience now it's
all getting a little blurry about if we're talking
about the inciting incident for the show or just
for this episode but either way let's just think
of it as the moment that everything changes and
The Dominoes start to fall but first according to
amazing after the inciting incident there's got
to be a refusal to act and it's honestly usually
out of cowardice before they can make the right
choice the hero tries really hard not to it's
that tug of war we talked about the yo-yoing of
the thesis and the antithesis they're pushing
and pulling until something snaps and for Craig
Mason this moment where he had to leave stasis
go on a limb and try to do the right thing
it came in 2015. by then Mason had already
been giving countless interviews where he kept
getting to ask hey what's next for you and he'd
often say that he was looking to write drama way
back in 2011 he ended an interview super excited
about a project he was working on even while
he was writing The Hangover too he said it's
the first non-comedy I've ever written it's
kind of a thriller and it's nice to flex that
muscle and show people there's another kind of
writing that I did that became identity [Music]
he wrote identity feed actually makes sense now
why the hangover of this whole video just made me
go like look at his comedy filmography now yeah
because The Hangover 3 was unusually a thriller
yes absolutely not much of a comedy it's not a
pleasant film I I don't like that one at all other
than knowing that like Craig Mason had this like
itch and he had just ridden a dramatic Thriller
but then next one became hangover I always put
that on Todd Phillips sure in the direction he was
going down because he would eventually do things
like war dogs and Joker and Joker so I thought
it was just Todd Phillips wanting to take it in
that direction yeah maybe he did maybe everybody
was like we're sick of this but you don't you
don't do that so it's just like funny to me to
be like wow I feel like there's something there
yeah why that became such a thriller and he's
clearly weren't movies that were gonna scratch
that drama itch for him but everything changed
in 2015. we can't know how many times Mason had
been trying to do drama but clearly it wasn't
sticky so he decided he was gonna quit on drama
at least if he didn't get this one last Hail Mary
of a project to Greenland he said if they don't
like it he wouldn't do it because something must
be wrong with him if they say no then he's just
wrong but in 2015 HBO said yes and Craig Mason
got to make Chernobyl and honestly nobody thought
he could do it his friend scriptnote's co-host and
a successful screenwriter in his own right John
August put it pretty clearly you doing Chernobyl
that is like Jason Statham doing a dromedy but
eventually the protection there's no way for them
working on some new adventure so for Joel this
time maybe because he was out of time or maybe
because he knew that the survival of his
darling his daughter or for Craig his story
that he obsessed with it required them to break
their rules and Go full steam ahead so they went
for it and they went hard pitched and I pitched
him pitched so now in making Chernobyl 20 years
into his career of screenwriting Craig Mason is
forced to learn new ways to connect to an audience
and make them care about the story he's telling
he's already taught us that a story needs ways
for people to connect to the characters but now
in Chernobyl and later in Last of Us he's adding
a layer to the story structure that's dedicated
to why now a lot of stories movies and television
shows demand a kind of discussion of relevance
that's because in stories audiences know well
either because they really happen like Chernobyl
or because we've just seen them so many times
like a zombie apocalypse viewers inherently lacked
empathy for the characters since they know where
things are going people act like they wouldn't
make the same mistakes so Mason says we have
to show them how we do make the same mistakes in
fact we are making them right now 2 today in the
real world so for Craig that is obsessed with
grounding his story about the 1986 meltdown of
a Soviet nuclear plant into the reality of that
moment of someone being as true to those moments
as possible but two having a why now connected
to our world at least at the time that he was
writing and here's what he said was dominating
the headlines at the time Trump did make a number
of false statements in the speech Trump's claim
is false Trump spent an entire day repeating a
false claim that President Obama literally is the
founder of Isis wasn't that the 2016 election was
known for lies but rather that America was having
this discussion about what the truth even was and
if we could trust our government to be honest with
us which unsurprisingly is why the Soviet people
let alone the rest of the world didn't even really
know what happened at Chernobyl they didn't know
what caused it and they didn't know why it took so
long to acknowledge its severity and so it's not
a surprise that the first spoken line in Mason's
Chernobyl is the cost of lies and here's the thing
doing the right thing Craig finally making it Joel
finally taking Swift action to acknowledge the
urgency of the events around him they don't get
replaced by acceptance of this new way of life
in fact Our Heroes still want to reject it they
might not believe in their original thesis anymore
but they're not yet willing to fully give in to
the antithesis so even though critics actually
completely loved Chernobyl and the Emmy goes to
Craig Mason and Joel had protected his daughter
from an attacker he'd successfully guided her out
of immediate danger according to Craig you have to
show that your Heroes aren't fully on board and
then you have to punish them both for taking the
risk and also for not giving themselves over to it
fully make your characters lower their defenses by
convincing them that everything's gonna be
okay and then punch them right in the face
so for Joel he's unwilling to transition to a
place of accepting new information and working on
action together a co-reliance instead he'd rather
keep Sarah in the dark prevent her from having new
information he's constantly trying to Shield her
perception from what's actually happening [Music]
you can look anywhere else what's really
sad is that this is a disagreement about
how to love someone Joel believes the way
to show love is to focus on protection
Sarah and Tommy they both believe that love is
shown in a willingness to rely on each other
loves you he's dependent on me not the same I
think it's the same I definitely the same and for
Craig cherished project that people objectively
acknowledge is fantastic but rather than fully
give in and accept that he's a great dramatic
writer he's still seeking out negative reviews
New York Times did not like the review was bad not
bad in the sense of they didn't like the show but
bad in the sense it was just it was poorly reading
my father it was stupid so Joel was wondering if
you can even face these new challenges and
Craig's List success might have been a fluke
like there's a reason they call historical dramas
and biopics Oscar bait did he take a shortcut
that means he's not actually a great dramatic
writer considering the feedback of the internet
where naysayers always exist Craig would have to
have a superhuman amount of self-assuredness to
actually resist the possibility that maybe his
success wasn't earned and so you're gonna have
to remember that mindset when I tell you what
insane project Craig Mason worked on next and
over to Joel he's still unable to look forward
it's actually Tommy that has the foresight to
know where things are going he even foreshadows
how the Army is not going to be their savior
I feel like you're right about all these things
that you're pointing out and I love that it's
being done in ways where there's deeper meanings
to it problem that I think often happens with a
lot of filmmaking is you go down a path where
you know your themes and you know what you want
to talk about and then you're just sort of talking
about that that's what you are communicating via
the dialogue of the characters and the actions
versus letting the characters be like real people
and then when you you know dive deeper into it
then you go oh there is a deeper meaning here to
what's going on so as you're presenting all this
audience can still connect with the immediacy of
everything that you're talking about all these
scenes you're pointing out a father protecting
his daughter that's why he's keeping his eyes
on her this whole time that's why he's saying
don't look at this because she's a young girl
but you know when you do break it down you are
seeing like what is the subconscious core belief
of this character that is coming through a brain
that is making him say and choose to do these
things without drawing attention to it in a way
of going look how brilliant we are yeah it's
using the language of behavior to have the
discussion rather than just making characters
sit down and talk about the thing [Music]
so moments later when this Soldier doesn't abide
by Joel's rules and how this all should work
behaving in a way that's correct amazing too I
mean but in a way Tommy might have anticipated
it leaves Joel flat-footed he just stands there
and it costs him everything as we now see his
watch is broken once again time freezes once more
for Joel some of his last words to Sarah simply
Another Broken promise you're gonna be okay now
at the start of act two I'm gonna get my watch
fixed to us what our protagonist is going to face
next you are taking their safety blanket away so
I want you to write your fearful hero honestly
what do they want a return to what they had they
want to go backwards and believe it or not that
is the gift that is going to drive you through
the second act and that's why 20 years after the
events of the prologue Joel's clinging to a frozen
life again he's closed off completely he wants
to retreat back to the idea that if he simply
accepts nothing new he'll stay safe after all a
monotonous disaffected life is still technically
living or is it I really want to see if Craig
Mason and conjunction with Neil druckman with all
these character choices that I have now been sold
on yeah that that is part of at least the show
it seems like it would be in conjunction with the
game but at least for the portrayal of Joel in the
show I would be curious to see if they go back to
some conversation or I don't know they want to do
a flashback like have a conversation where you see
why Joel turned into that individual who thinks
and behaves this way you know like we're seeing
that he is that way but I want to know like how
we developed into that basically like in 2003 like
how he became before everything goes well no yeah
this this resistance against time and yeah this
thing to shut off things about reality because
that setup of him as a character who has this
resistance against time is in correlation with
who he is 20 years later because he has a hard
time just sort of accepting the reality of things
yeah and Sarah and Sarah's death can't be the the
originating cause of that they're like it's almost
like an Aftershock that makes that part of his
character that much more entrenched so yeah what
led him to becoming this guy in the first place
yeah the child who wanders toward the quarantine
Zone shows us what the future holds for something
that is technically alive but barely taking in
its surroundings and that mindless trudging
toward the New Frontier hesitation because of
what he's been through a healthy distrust of where
things might go next that all might be what Craig
Mason was feeling when he agreed to take on his
next project after Chernobyl this what oh [__]
I feel a guitar today maybe a leopard okay I'm not
gonna pretend Charlie's Angels was some insanely
terrible movie when I tell you what insane
project Craig Mason worked on next I said it
was an insanely terrible it was kind of an insane
follow-up to Chernobyl though that's only because
after years and years of the lighthearted fair
that seemed so unfulfilling for that reason you'd
think you'd want to focus on the work that would
beat his soul he spent years talking about wanting
to get a chance to show his dramatic Chomps
not his karate chops I'm sorry the good news
is so did he because for some reason or another
Craig Mason actually left that project after only
a short while of working on it you didn't take
this job to fix other people's grammar or fetch
me tuna sandwiches and tap job because you have a
vision for yourselves and where he went well that
was that up I'll tell you this is something that
I honestly never thought that I would be able to
work on it's a game called The Last of Us it is
my favorite video game and I play them all the
story is remarkable too remarkable it made me
feel things and what makes him taking on this
project all the more interesting is just how scary
it is for him to do it it's a fear that never used
to exist after reflection perhaps I'm not the
right person to be writing this story or that
story but it is a fear I mean the video game
Community is not shy so I would say you must
do the thing you're afraid of you must it's the
caves here to answer hold the answers you see yes
and video game fans aren't the only people to be
concerned about Neil druckman the creator of The
Last of Us famously blew off Craig Mason when he
reached out to him about it damn but that's the
point of act two you have to put the protagonist
in a situation where there's no going back and the
likelihood of failure is extremely high but you
also want the hero's past to be custom designed
to make them the exact right person to tackle this
new adventure only someone who has experienced the
loss of a child is going to be able to fully grasp
the importance of keeping another child alive and
only someone who has survived the deepest pits
of critical rejection has the resilience to
withstand The Impossible pressures being placed
on this project both heroes are going to have
the benefits and the wisdom of their losses to
calibrate themselves for this journey so for
Craig when he planned the story for the last of us
he was able to use every aspect of his career to
ensure he'd knock it out of the park with the show
and some of the parts of his career history that
he's using are actually pretty surprising but
we'll get back to those wait a minute what was
that graphic there yeah it was like Journey
language balance patience oh that's cool
did you make this graphic damn the crafts
empathetic characters hold X to grade I
would of a script writing software that is a
video game like this yeah be nice let's start
with how what he learned on Chernobyl comes into
play here like we referenced earlier Chernobyl had
this shortcut to Stakes based on the fact that hey
that thing really happened on that show Craig took
small Liberties to add in some fiction to a mostly
non-fiction retelling but could the opposite work
too on the last of us could Craig Mason take a
mostly fiction story and with some small Liberties
add in some non-fiction that could ground the
show to at least some level of the realism that
Chernobyl I think yeah you can and here's how he
does it we've already seen some nods to real world
issues the opener had the global warming reference
and the thing about a viral pandemic yeah it's a
new virus in Madagascar say it could be in Chicago
within a matter of weeks and that threat even
makes it all the way to 2003 where for some reason
a student in Sarah's class wears an n95 style mask
in front of an ironic sign that we'll get back to
except these are all just the obvious parallels to
the carnival but do you remember earlier when
I said I'm actually not talking about covet
here by the way but more on that later I think in
order to connect this to the stakes of our world
today but still with the severity of something as
solemn as Chernobyl Craig Mason and Neil druckman
made purposeful connections to anti-Semitism and
the most traumatic event in modern Jewish history
the Holocaust I know that's so heavy but you got
to remember the best way for us to analyze the
intent of the creators of the show is to focus on
the changes that they made from the story that we
experience in the game I feel like visually I
mean you know you're focusing on the pilot but
I they're I'm getting flashes of moments in
episode four when Joel and Ellie are hiding
out away from the hunters and stuff there's so
much imagery that does evoke that maybe not of
real life documentaries or something like that
but you know at least the best of the World War
II Holocaust movies yeah Mass dead occupations
things like that the way they hide out and the
kind of hideouts that they're in at the time
there are a lot of those visual imageries that
certainly evoke that kind of vibe and so as
we move forward I'll go ahead and give you a
warning now that this is pretty dark material
here when the TV show story gets to 2023 this
entire section with the wandering child is made
new just for the show and it's the first of many
analogous moments to the treatment of Jewish
people in the 1930s and 40s for instance as the
child approaches the quarantine Zone with barbed
wire and signage similar to the Jewish ghettos in
places like Poland he's taken by officers of fedra
in the games this bedroom represents the fascist
military dictatorship that took power away
from the US government in response to the
fungal outbreak in real life the nsdap was
Hitler's political party who had been given
control of German police forces they used a
global economic crisis the one from the 1920s
to take their power and then they used that power
to Institute the mandatory relocation of Jewish
families from their homes rounding them up into
trucks secretly Bound for concentration camps all
under an endless parade of false pretenses those
people falling out of their cattle trucks have
boarded them believing they were being taken
to new lives in a new place the Nazis lied
to their victims at every step of their Journey
towards destruction actually it was harder than I
expected he's taken to a sanitation area which
is some of that concentration camps was often
referred to as a quarantine Zone it began with
a forced trip to the showers typhus was claiming
500 lives a month if it had only been prisoners
who are at risk the SS would not have worried but
the Nazis dreaded this disease for themselves
does because of real concerns like typhus in
addition to totally [__] concerns about other
needs for sanitation with the camps themselves
actually being way less sanitary than the outside
world and just like how the lies continue in the
show lies tied to the concept of Sanitation or
medicine were delivered to all the people who
entered the camps what if I told you that after
we gave you some medicine find your favorite
[Music]
favorites you want to play with the difference
between truth and lies can be the difference
between life and death similarly as the Jewish
people who were selected for sanitation were
led to the showers they were made promises about
how after these warm showers they'd be given new
wardrobes soon and feasts awaited these were the
Jews final minutes but the Nazis encouraged them
to believe in a future they did not have what is
your trade a Shoemaker the officer would ask we
need them urgently report to me immediately after
the line just kept going it was holster and dress
in this one and those in the same room they were
even told to remember the place where they put
their clothes that was when the reminder would
come to tile shoes into pairs so that afterwards
you won't have to waste time finding the other
shoe in fact the SS were thinking practically
the shoes of murdered children would only
be of use back home if they came in pairs
there's actually a pretty famous Memorial site
that shows these Wow shoes left over from some
of these final victims and it kind of makes you
wonder where this shoelaces for sale in the Boston
quarantine zone are from now you might watch this
scene and felt for the soldier who maybe was just
trying to bring some comfort to this boy in his
last moment you're safe and that might even be
a greater system though but also you should keep
in mind that after 20 years of this it's pretty
likely that these are just standard systematic
precautions that would be in place to prevent any
risk so it's strength to keep the Easter parties
caught they're afraid of the possible Panic among
them and if we're being honest some of those
lies are a lot less comforting than the others
we don't want you falling out of the chair
now again I know this can seems please yeah
I don't think so at all connected the severity
of those horrific events in history to the events
of this fictional TV show I'm just trying to
point out that the intent behind the scripting
very likely was purposely trying to make these
connections remember aside from the depiction
of the Federer everything I've just mentioned
was newly added to the story by Craig Mason and
Neil druckman and sure Craig Mason often talks
about his Jewish Heritage you know how Jewish
I am I'm so Jewish you guys nobody's as Jewish
as I am but he's also spoken a bit about Neil
drugman Neil druckman he created the the game
and the story and he is Israeli he's definitely
more of a oh while Craig and Neil were hard
at work on the scripting of this TV show at
the same exact time Neil was hard at work on the
last of us too the sequel video game Craig and
I started working while we were at Naughty Dog
finishing lasso's part two so Craig would come
over for lunches and we would start breaking the
season what I had no idea wow that's crazy because
there are like references without going too big
here to the second game for sure and I could have
swore wow that's just like wild to me I mean could
have snailed drug from to multitask like that yeah
but I really felt like they had the two games and
then they wanted to like borrow elements from it
but to be part of that kind of just changes up
the game on the creative process when you could
be there while the creativity is happening for
the second game and then how to really take that
over it's a different way of absorption versus I
played the first game I want to adapt this and now
you're absorbing how the world's going to continue
and what elements or story lines can I bring over
to here for the show it's just insane to me and
it's so much of a time difference that I'm like
God damn this [__] takes forever to make both
both of them have to take forever to make and it
makes you two Wonder like I'm sure they didn't
hamper anything for one project or the other but
yeah like how did the formulation of the show
affect at all if maybe the formulation of Last
of Us Part Two and vice versa you know yeah it's
fascinating to think about and that game had some
very overt references to Jewish culture this place
is a synagogue how can you tell that was a percent
Dina's character even including comparisons of
their post-apocalyptic struggles to those of
Jewish history I like coming from a long line
of survivors you mean after outbreak day that
and the Holocaust playing the game you even find
this letter from a rabbi that literally Compares
his grandfather escaping the Holocaust to his
family escaping the outbreak the common connection
he finds is that despite the difficulties it's
people living people who matter so now you might
not be as surprised to see when throughout
the series there are all kinds of references
some more blatant than others like in episode 3
and the government are all Nazis the government
are all Nazis or more subtle references to Jewish
culture like this quick glimpse of a man wearing
a Gore Lieberman shirt which is doubly relevant
by the way because Joe Lieberman was the first
Jewish person on a U.S presidential ticket but
also back in two thousand 6 Al Gore won an Oscar
for his documentary about our failures to deal
with global warming the presidency in 2000 global
warming could have maybe been staved off maybe the
cordyceps outbreak could have been prevented who
knows but actually I think druckman's reasons
for invoking the Holocaust go deeper than just
a surface level purpose because you see when
the last of us two did come out it was very
well documented that the game had these very clear
themes related to the israeli-palestinian conflict
and for some people that was a very controversial
inclusion that ended up creating this heightened
tone around the game's discourse so then when an
actor compared the experience of playing the game
to the harrowing emotions brought up by watching
a film like Schindler's List people got really mad
in particular this one journalist dug in pretty
hard and with the internet being the internet
not only did this somehow spawn a bit of a meme
where people would write jokes about video games
being compared to incredibly tragic historical
events but then that same journalist joked that
oh my God Jesus got directly responded to by
Neil druckman himself and if you didn't follow
gaming news or discourse you might have missed
this controversy but it actually did go pretty
far and wide to the point where eventually
and again as he was working on the scripts
for this Show with Craig Mason druckman shared
how severe the anti-semitic attacks became no
rather than focus on any particular side of that
debate I want to step back and acknowledge how
it makes sense then that amidst all of this the
show's creators were feeling that the topic of
anti-Semitism was particularly front of mind at
the time and also if you follow yes you said the
last few months sure still something that people
are currently a thousand percent on both sides
I'm referring to her space lasers to Kanye West
Kanye West anti-semitic incidents in the U.S it
reached an all-time high last year and here's
where it connects back to these storytelling
techniques of Craig Mason because it's not just
about a connection between our world and the
world of the story but rather connection to the
central dramatic argument and if you remember for
the last of us that argument is that there's no
greater risk than inaction looking away hoping for
problems to resolve themselves so in some ways
Craig Mason it's like he's a protagonist's Own
Story yeah and by doing a thing like the show is
taking that action without it feeling like Craig
Mason is talking to me yeah yeah he's just letting
the show and character and story do its thing it's
beautiful because he seems like the kind of writer
who is capable of doing that anyway and then to
think that it is such like a close collaboration
with Neil druckman who also has I think you know
probably similar levels of passion and concern
for you know the dramatic nature of the real world
it's fascinating to behold and like even though
I'm sure you know we can draw narratives out of
anything this does feel like an interestingly
timed project with his growth as a person
and as a creative in this life yeah Ken Burns
probably the most famous documentarian alive he
just released a brand new film specifically about
how that's the same exact message America failed
to learn during the Holocaust I just want to say
I love how you implemented the Ken Burns effect
don't think I didn't notice that session because
I didn't know Ken Burns was a person after I was
already Ken burnson in an iMovie Kim burns
with the best of them we were very surprised
to learn that even as early as 1933 there were
thousands and thousands of newspaper articles and
reports that we did have evidence that something
terrible was happening Burns even goes so far oh
my God blame a number of deaths on America's
mistake of inaction that's on Roosevelt it's
on the state department it's on the Congress
but it's also on the American people and just
like Craig Mason knows that a central dramatic
argument from our past is only interesting to
us if we can learn how to relate that argument
to our today Ken Burns is doing the same thing
sequence near the end of the film includes some
very recent events Charlottesville chance of Jews
will not replace us a camp Auschwitz sweatshirt
at the Capitol on January 6th that's clear from
watching this the time to save a democracy is
before it's lost prevention this is studying
the differences between fiction and non-fiction
we're seeing here that both forms of Storytelling
are equally capable of teaching us the same
lesson and Craig Mason seems to think it's
especially true when they can borrow a little
bit from each other so as we move forward a new
world of Boston Post pandemic a few more tragic
circumstances that are analogous to the Holocaust
become apparent with the public executions the
replacement of money with internal credits and
cigarette currency to having to hide tools and
valuables and tragically the people of the camp
responsible for the incineration of their
own fellow man and it's clear that the only
way someone can steal themselves for this dire a
life is to completely disassociate this woman was
struggling to throw the boy's body into the fire
but Joel does it without freaking blinking it's
like the dinosaur foreshadowed he's pretending
he's moved on from mourning a child but the fact
that he still wears the gift of the ever broken
watch is a reminder that deep down he's still
suffering basically he's in the simplest form
of survival mode which would have actually been
pretty familiar for Craig Mason who spent years of
his career not just on those spoof films but also
as a go-to script doctor picking up any odd job
separating fulfillment from his career with the
need to make a living this is what made it so much
more impressive for Craig to make these dramatic
projects because he openly has admitted they don't
pay nearly as well as the other work he was doing
I'm going to spend a lot of time now on something
that I'm not going to make a lot of money on but
I just care about though they can't say that why
that's an American way it goes uncredited on a lot
of the scripts he works on and Joel well he's
clearly done some bad stuff in these last two
decades dates including smuggling drugs to the
fascists it's actually ironic that a twitching
hand in Sarah's classroom was designed of a
possible underlying infection because the same
could be said for this officer's twitching hands
except his infection is one of addiction showing
the soldiers this way is also a new addition to
the story and while in some ways it humanizes them
it's also another connection to the crystal meth
and opiate addictions of Nazi soldiers what Joel
says oh really I didn't know about that yeah the
more you shoot people the harder it is to sleep I
guess now I know this analysis feels like it's
taken this pretty dark turn but I think that's
because the story really does too in fact it's
appropriate that the first episode's title is
when you're lost in the darkness now of course the
concern that when working on something so precious
after so much serious work and conversation and
just darkness is that Craig just like Joel could
lose himself in that Darkness certainly Neil
druckman's recent experiences weren't really
providing much levity to the situation
just like how Joel shows no signs of
acknowledging his sweet even sometimes kind
of silly past with his daughter we stopped
having any sort of semblance to a connection to
Craig's past as a comedy writer it's all as dark
as Chernobyl but with an even higher body count
so now we have Craig on this mission to deliver
this incredibly serious somber piece that's
gonna prove that video game adaptations can
work and Joel on a mission to save his brother
though arguably he might not even need saving
and both are doing it just like the truck without
the battery so it seems like that one of the keys
is the classic thing of what makes great writing
and storytelling is allowing yourself to throw
yourself into this store in a weird way it could
be unintentional or intentional but some type of
honesty about yourself and vulnerability about
yourself and allow that to be weaved in as the
story progresses that is the the question posed
at the top of this is how do you make it and how
do you identify the emotion and I feel like like
with everything that's being broken down in this
video keeps coming back to Craig Mason and his
shitty spoof coming let's just ruined his life
and put him in the most despairing Place possible
I think that's what people really are getting at
when they say right which you know it's not just
like oh take something that you know the details
about it's like take the life that applies to you
and the experiences and imbue the story with those
debates and issues and feelings somehow rather
than just like you were an accountant right About
Accountants I feel like it gets boiled down that
way but yeah like take this life and find a way
to make this apply to the fiction you're you're
telling there's some essential component missing
from these utilitarian missions so we get the
same solution for both of them enter Ellie born
in this absolute Darkness she is the light we meet
her and she's bathed in it she speaks and we get
the first thing resembling a lighter tone in this
entire post-apocalyptic world seven eight eight
[__] you she's not just a spot of brightness in
Joel's future she's actually an outlet for Craig
Mason to bring in a sense of Comedy that exists
in the world too and I don't say that to me that
this show needs joke breaks what do you want
I want you to forget this ever happened done
now your [__] has pretty much ruined my week and
I'd like to go home and drink till
my face stops hurting so are we good
release the left track cut
[Laughter]
there's a wacky version of this whole show
somewhere in a drawer I don't know what Craig
Mason thinks of that SNL sketch that they did of
The Last of Us he wrote and directed the Mario one
oh I haven't seen it yet if it's more of a spoof
of Mario but brought it HBO sensibility in general
yeah okay I get but there's like Pedro Pascal
stars in it so I think that would be oh I want to
know his response to that it's gonna Inspire him
maybe we could change it to season two a little
bit now um second Mario Brothers movie Craig Mason
will take over I say bring back some of that spoof
comedy material Craig Mason yeah you got plenty
of zombie and infection movies to draw for him
just start throwing blatant references I say that
because even on our darkest days the real world
still has moments of levity there's another zombie
show that personally got a bit hard for me to
watch not only because it was becoming exhausting
to always be dwelling in death like crazy
ex-girlfriend Mason told us in one of the very
first episodes of his podcast over 10 years ago
that he knows deep down comedy and drama should
coexist whether you're writing a drama or a comedy
you must be writing drama they really aren't
that different oh also you might have noticed
that Ellie lied about her name with Veronica being
a slightly fitting name for the role that she's
gonna play for these men since Saint Veronica at
least uh in non-canonical Bible stories she's the
woman who saw Jesus bearing the cross on his
way to Calvary and in her own small way as she
reached out and supported him she offered him
her veil to wipe his blood and sweat from his
face these Jewish writers implemented my Bible
speaking to it didn't click until just now with
the whole Christian thing and now I'm on board
yeah before I was like I don't know about this
second he bring some Jesus talk into here I'm on
board now I'm like now that's my Jew Amen brother
you're not Jews for Jesus of course this isn't the
type of Salvation that Joel's hoping for since he
clearly prefers the Roadies onward test unlike
what Sarah would have wanted this is almost a
Bizarro relationship to the one he had with her
here neither person wants to take responsibility
for the other and both seem eager to break
promises now I promised Robert that he wouldn't
hurt him very much like Joel even finds himself on
the opposite end of the withholding of information
well where is he don't know Daddy don't know is
it from terrorists no no that's likely because
this isn't the actual relationship he needs in
his life Tess has a bit smaller role in the game
and while her character is actually fascinating
here it doesn't make their parent any healthier
they're both happy to live in stasis and we see
what extended stasis does to a person moments
later the infected who was less there on his own
the fungus eventually fully overtook him he grew
into the wall there's no bit of humanity left
that's very near where we find Joel these days
the the thing is this Behavior it's not because
of the tragedy the world's experience is still
representative of Joel's own individual issues we
know this because if Joel comes to function as a
pseudo Father Figure to Ellie we can look back at
her relationship with Marlene as that of a pseudo
mother figure this all is a lot more apparent in
the game but Ellie even asks Marlene my [__]
Joel and Marlene feel responsibility to protect
Ellie but even this early on in the story we
know they have completely different philosophies
about who's worthy of living and the value of one
person versus the greater good you need it for
a better reason than you they don't know offense
but Tommy's just one man yeah it's actually really
fascinating because Joel while experiencing lossy
he knew of the world prior to this outbreak where
Ellie while there's some traumas to uncover that
at that time of recording this video the show
has not necessarily fully gone into just yet so
I don't want to talk about it but Ellie represents
someone who's born post this outbreak yet is
very much more humorous she seems to be more
engaged and Lively and it's it is an interesting
parallel to draw because you got a guy who is so
traumatized and so affected but he at least knew
of a life before all this where Ellie born into
this so what you're saying about this all boils
down to Joel as an individual that's what I was
trying to get out early here when I was like I
wanted to see why he is the way he is prior to
uncovering that individual piece because he's
always sort of been this way it's just only been
Amplified by day of outbreak and 20 plus 20 years
or something Marlene actually represents another
nuanced connection to our real world which Tess
clearly labels for us it's Che guevar of Boston
Che was a controversial figure whose role in
history kind of depends on who you ask some people
think his revolutionaries had the right idea but
others call out that just like the fireflies in
pursuit of something that could be Noble they were
far too willing to let innocent people get hurt
nonetheless revolutionaries are known for taking
action and responding to the times oh yeah cool
as we know still believe something closer to the
opposite of that in fact as he tells Ellie what
are you doing killing time the dude is literally
killing time in the middle of one of the craziest
days of this girl's life he hates time the only
effort he's willing to put in is to actively
prevent Ellie from being able to engage with them
further specifically in the same way his daughter
did because like Sarah Ellie quickly guesses
there's a secret way to communicate with Joel
through music the radio is a smuggling code right
he's like bumblebee I'm just talking through the
radio [Laughter] it's why her first observation
of the man is this your watch is broken just
like Sarah Ellie knows that watch represents
everything wrong with troll except what's
different about Ellie from Sarah is that
Ellie belongs in this world she's more at home in
this world than she would have been in Sarah's we
may meet both of them near windows but Ellie's
difference is symbolized by the butterfly that
hangs over this one just like how an infected
human normally goes through a metamorphosis to
become something monstrous Ellie will soon learn
is technically infected yet she's transforming
into something beautiful a harmonious balance
between a desolate human existence and a thriving
fungal one this is actually New Testament fungal
form of her and Joel at the end of the opening
credits but there's actually a much better
symbol for them but I'm going to get to in
a minute but before that remember when I told
you in a tug of war between two ideas thesis
and an anti-thesis they'll land somewhere
in the middle a point we call synthesis
that's what Ellie is she's the synthesis of
the Two Worlds and of the two philosophers
but a complete subservient Reliance to somebody
isn't right either Ellie represents the idea that
we need to cool forward and mutually lean on each
other as we go that way I think most of the show
is going to take place in this act two of Joel's
character Arc but I do think we've had a few
moments that could represent the final Maze and
story step that I'm going to go over the element
of doubt this element of Doubt creates a natural
conflict with the protagonist because of course
I believe this you believe that but they have
to have the capacity to see that maybe there is
a better way we've seen this tug of war continued
a few times but the biggest example is right here
when Joel's brought back to the exact moment time
stopped for him way back in 2003. the moment where
inaction caused his daughter her life so going out
on a limb he decides to take a risk instead of the
weak pleading and otherwise just standing there he
makes a different choice this time he takes action
[Music] foreign the ripples of action do mean
that the clock is ticking again Joel's never
going to be able to return to his ordinary world
but at least now he still has his daughter figure
there to protect it turns out his purpose
isn't ruined by taking action and this deeply
challenges Joel's belief system and the Depeche
Mode song that plays never let me down again it
hints at what new beliefs are for me Joel will
be Ellie's friend he'll be there to protect her
as long as she listens to him and follows his
rules he's not going to let his daughter down
again I love cues like this and Craig Mason
isn't gonna let us down either because he's
the exact right person to adapt this show
hangover for one of them oh this you know
what I I do love it I love it I love God I love
it that's because everything he's ever worked on
has led to this moment all the things that you do
prior to something were necessary for one reason
or another to get you to what you're doing at
this moment yes he has a deep appreciation for
video games and yes he's experiencing creating a
serious successful show that posed complex social
questions but it's his lifetime experience and
his comedic writing that makes him so perfect
for this yes even the spoof movies writing a
spoof movie is just about loving a genre so
deeply that you understand the nuances of the
category and [__] great Point great ass boy
down beloved genres like horror superhero movies
and identify the parts that most resonate with
the audience he's now doing that for the zombie
genre and the HBO massive World built-in genre in
the video games are even a little bit of Western
is thrown in there he's pulling the parts we need
as an audience to connect to our favorite elements
of those genres and the reason he's so dang good
at it is because of those spoof movies unlike an
impression or a coffee or an homage those movies
are graded on whether or not they click with a
feeling the audience has about that genre it's
like how the best comedians know it's their
ability to empathize with the audience that
is key to them accepting their message which is
how a good stand-up is able to play a room full
of people like an instrument his or her words can
control the emotions of an entire Audience by just
knowing how to relate to them so comedy taught
Craig Mason how to tell the stories of flawed
people spoof movies taught him how to create
relatable moments in flawed genres and the two
together have given us a familiar genre but with a
deeper human connection to it than we've ever felt
before because comedy isn't about thousand zombies
piling on top of each other like he has to get
over a wall comedy is about The Human Condition
there needs to be a period of resistance and then
we begin the adventure just as I said what Ali
represents for Joel The Last of Us represents for
Craig Mason he knows the two sides of the argument
are tired of pulling away from each other and I'm
not telling Craig Mason this he's telling us
don't worry he's got this I mean look at all
the work he put into just structuring this thing
and the attention to detail because of his love
for this project and his desire to get it right
oh and speaking of those great details remember
a few minutes ago when I told you but there's
actually a much better symbol for them that I'm
going to get to in a minute now before I tell you
what that symbol is I gotta thank you for watching
this video this far this is a brand new channel
and like Joel and like Craig we're also going out
on a limb here we're trying to take a chance and
do some something different hopefully we're making
something people want if you're a supporter on
patreon by the way thank you so much we cannot do
it without you and if you're not that's fine too
you can help us out by subscribing commenting and
mostly sharing this video with other people
you think it would resonate with trust me
and speaking of that private playlists
relationships that's the symbol of synthesis
I wanted to share with you the symbol that
represents Craig in this show our relationship
with him and with Neil the needed balance between
the natural world of the fungus and the artificial
constructions of man and Joel's relationship
with Ellie it's in the final shots of the very
first episode the buildings yeah we see these
buildings more clearly in episode two but for
now remember this is Craig's directorial debut
after over a decade this is what he wants us
to focus on this symbolism in this moment two
utilitarian Towers covered in natural growth
leaning on each other in a mutually Reliant
love just like the kind Sarah believed in all
amidst a storm of danger we still hear the
words oh [__] man soundtrack The Thunder
crashing and even an infected Screech at least
for now he's got me man you're awesome it's not
going anywhere it's persevering it's in perfectly
synthesized balance and it as far as symbols go
it might outlive them all but for now it's a great
snapshot of what really is the last of us actually
great superim position fantastic man that was
amazing a plus man this is inspiring what I really
loved about your video here is it's really easy
to get lost in the technical side of what you're
doing like oh this is different you're sitting
and there's multiple camera angles you got one on
a on a track slowly moving around there's a lot of
beautiful fanciful editing going on throughout and
great visuals like it was like the production
quality on it was insane but the thing that
I really want to credit you on right now is you
still look like you're in good shape so good job
after all that I know you're just perfectly yeah
yeah good job man I know it's hard to get that
shirt you're still keeping it up it accentuates
your muscles that look like you're trying too
hard no what I want to say is that the video like
buys you into like all right we're getting some
different subject ideas and then as opposed to
Leading with the really dark deeper stuff like
super deep dark stuff like like the Holocaust
parallels and whatnot and what I love is that
you told the story here about a store and you
still made it like a character-driven narrative
via through Craig Mason journey of adapting this
and I thought that was really cool because you
know you're especially when you're ending this
video off I'm being inspired by this journey
you're sending out with film wise I think that is
very present here with how this video narratively
is structured like I found myself going down like
the dark Death paths with the video as it's being
presented and then it comes back with a hopeful
end it's like you found the the synthesis at the
very end as well within your own video and I think
that's really clever of how this was done yeah I
thought this was uh an actual it felt like a
documentary yeah you know you said part one
and I thought it was going to end on like a real
Cliffhanger of sorts and it doesn't feel that way
like this really feels like something that could
be on television because a story was told like
oh exciting we're introducing a new topic we're
going to go into the weeds of things and we're
gonna go real dark then we're gonna swing back
to something a little bit more hopeful and on
top of that you were also telling the Craig Mason
journey and how that's affected your life and I
think that's really cool I really really love the
way this was done because there's so much emotion
into it versus just breakdowns or really intuitive
insightful video essay because it's kind of all
that but more yeah I feel like what's so lovely
about this especially for for me as viewers like
yeah you can look at any piece of art or whatever
it is in a vacuum and and examine it for its own
merits and what it's trying to say just as a
piece on its own but what often resonates with
me just in my own time or if I'm enamored with a
project is learning about the people who made it
and kind of understanding what came together in
the real world to produce what I'm enjoying so
much now and I think here yeah you did a great
job people narrative eyes life but this didn't
feel too contrived or anything like that or
like you're forcing this Craig Mason's story
to parallel like it felt very natural and yeah
like an interesting and grossing tale about how
this got made and and why these people why now but
also yeah what is it doing Beyond just oh here's
how it's kind of like the game or here's how it
nods to this movie or yeah interesting uh sort of
documentary on the Vitality of all these things
I mean even how you brought it around with Craig
Mason and his struggles with the time when he was
working in comedies you know so much of this kept
seeming like all right you know he had a hard time
with comedies he was burnt out by Hollywood and it
wasn't really wanted to do then he found Chernobyl
all right but you're just wrapping it all around
too but that's what led him here and here's
what he learned from there that allowed that
again it's like Craig Mason what you're talking
about with this whole thing with thesis and and
antithesis when you're talking about those I'm
like you're also doing that with Craig Mason
threat and I didn't really even see that until the
ending like oh [__] he's the synthesis Phillips
video is doing the thing you know as opposed
to just telling it you are we are experiencing
it and I think that's cool like I really found
this video to actually be an experience 100 and
a narratively really enjoyable one so this was
uh there's nothing quite like this that I I've
seen because it's doing like all the things that
I love from you know anything from like what heavy
spoilers will do to Patrick H Willems to high
top films like you're doing all that but with
like this Netflix level type of documentary it's
like some kind of cable special or something like
that you might tune into like the yeah it's
really polished and really Punchy and really
engaging I was really impressed with this because
I was expecting it more be like all right there's
some cool like information in here it's not like
an Easter egg video but it's in some ways like
the ultimate Easter egg video the Thematic Easter
eggs yeah yeah it is it is breaking down why this
project is as great as it is and as rich as it is
and as personal as it is and I wasn't expecting
to find something that would be so moving and
inspiring because it's inspiring on the level of
seeing how Craig Mason got to where he is but
it's also inspiring that this is put together
because everyone was telling me like it's such
an impressive video and you know you kind of
just expect yeah it's probably like really
cool to look at and I love Last of Us so I'm
sure it'll be good yeah but I was not expecting
the the kind of Journey that we went on and how
clever it is without it seeming without you
even telling me without like I mean like not
like Philip texting me I mean like you it's
like telling me in the video like and see if
I've done the thing too oh [__] he's done
the thing but without saying that you've done
the thing well in that way I think that's part
of what separates something like this out too
is because not to not to slight anybody else's
approach but this one it's like you could watch
this both for your appreciation of just the show
in the game as they are but also you could study
this for writing tips and things like that because
it's a comprehensive place to show the Creator's
input but also then to extrapolate breakdown
and illustrate how that approach then is put
to work and then you're demonstrating it's kind
of like you brought up that thing about parodies
and spoofs about like you have to know the thing
inside and out in order to authentically provide
that kind of experience in here I feel like in
breaking down the approach to story like you
said synthesis uh you know thesis antithesis and
then synthesis you you demonstrated that here in
what feels like a very graceful and articulate
way and so it's like you can get your fan Rush
from this but you can also get your creative you
know nutrition in a way it feels like from this
too like I get why this took you so long to
put together so you can't do this once a week
I know you had some help here but I know like
it's mainly you who edited this video and uh
with help from the lady you're dating uh what's
Rachel yes Rachel shouts out to Rachel I think
the writing on this it's really easy to just
look at the production quality of what you
have assembled here but this is the script on
this is pretty nominal I am really Blown Away
by what I just watched it is it's intimidating it
is yeah it's like intimidating and inspiring so
I'm just gonna look at my most recent Last of Us
reaction view count to feel better about myself
you're doing great don't tell
your channel is just way too big
I only got like that many views and
now it makes sense why you have this
many views now no you always trend
on this thing that was wild that was
a tour de force that was wild because
yeah I was like man it's a long video
the thing is it doesn't feel like it's what just
shy of an hour like I was so engrossed and then we
were done and I was like oh we're here we're here
already yeah no I think everything all around was
um pretty spectacular pitch this to TV man
this really could be this really could be
a show or like a screening you got invited to for
somebody's yeah like yeah not quite feature length
documentary but you know it's just as good as that
anyone deserves to interview Craig Mason it's you
and that's that's what I feel right now part way
through watching this I was like you know you
never know how anybody will feel but I I hope he
sees this and appreciates it and feels validated
right there's another Hall in New York Times
piece such a [__] video and then he'll write
his own version of this video yeah it'll be even
better um yeah guys subscribe to filmwise I hope
your next one comes out sooner than later this was
phenomenal yeah I really mean that this hats off
this is truly phenomenal also we'll talk with you
guys soon again and watch the original video link
at least go go there and give it a like
all right I'll see you guys soon [Music]